Arizona Senator John McCain lies in
state today at the Arizona Capitol
beginning four days of public mourning
retired Air Force colonel and former
POWs on fer shared a cellblock with John
McCain in Vietnam we spoke with fer
about his reaction to McCain's death and
what then candidate Donald Trump said
about the senator while on the campaign
trail America is gonna feel the absence
of John McCain I spent you know those
months and a couple of years pacing the
floor with him back and forth and
talking and I got a very good sense of
the depth of John if you were in Hanoi
and you heard that somebody running for
president said about a captive I like
heroes who weren't captured would you
believe that they said it I think it's a
really really sad commentary to say any
American captive who was put who had put
his life on the line and and risked it
for it as John says they caused greater
than himself
what was your reaction when you heard
Donald Trump had said that I couldn't
believe it
I couldn't believe somebody would say
that about a national hero when you'd
see him on TV his and you can't always
be in touch with him what would you
think back to I saw the the John McCain
that I knew that was the mixture of
seriousness of the moment but he had
almost he almost had a glimmer of a
humor that wanted to come out and say
look that this is serious business but
we've got a we've got to remember don't
lose your sense of humor you know look
on the bright side when I see him in in
in those interviews when I see him
sitting behind the desk at his committee
meetings and things like that that's
what I see with John I see an
exceptionally knowledgeable guy who was
able despite and he's had he had it by
his own admission he had lots of
setbacks in his in his public life he
always bounced back and he was a man
I love that interview yesterday John
because he really showed us a different
side of John McCain what he talked about
his storytelling and his comedic touch
yeah yeah and because they had to
entertain themselves they had movie
night but there's no screen they just
acted out the movie he told him talked
about acting out the Christmas Carol and
McCain playing Scrooge described him as
Charlie Chaplin he was a he I mean he
feels it in his bones how long were they
together in kaday working together for
two years in the same cellblock and fur
was there a total of six years
incredible really